ALEX DANILO: Once upon a
time there was a little girl
and a little boy who traveled
through the woods and got lost.
And they came up
with a great idea
of dropping bread
crumbs along the way
so they could find
their way home.
I'm Alex Danilo.
And I want to talk about modern
bread crumbs in the form of GPS
crumbs for your mobile phone.
There are thousands
of apps out there
that track you
when you're moving.
And when you're
moving across space,
you can grab GPS crumbs-- for
example, when you're driving,
or cycling, or walking.
Now this is great, except for
the problem of GPS jitter.
If you're traveling
along a road,
and you grab a whole lot
of crumbs along the way,
chances are they won't actually
connect to the road you're
traveling on.
Like, for example, if
I grab these 10 crumbs,
and then I try to draw
a line between them,
it actually crosses
through buildings
and doesn't follow the
road I was traveling on.
This is due to a few
different reasons,
like taking too few samples
along the way, or inaccuracy
in the GPS crumb collection.
But with the Roads API, it
provides a service where you
can pass in your GPS crumbs
and get GPS crumbs back that
actually snap to the road you've
been travelling on, and provide
interpolation between them.
So you can create
beautiful visualizations
of GPS tracks of the roads
that you've been traveling on.
Now, you can pass quite
a few crumbs at a time.
And for example,
if you pass in 100,
and say, interpolate it for
me, and generate the curves,
you can get maybe 300 back.
And this way you can plot
an accurate visualization
of where you've been driving.
Say you're building an app
to record your driving so you
can compare with your friends.
Or if you're cycling,
you might want
to know what your
personal best is.
And your app does this for you.
Now the Roads API
gives you a perfect way
to visualize this on your phone
with complete accuracy using
Google's map data.
Roads API also provides metadata
for enterprise customers.
For example, if you're
building an asset tracker,
you can get speed limits
for roads you've traveled.
So if I've gong from
point A to point B,
I can visualize it by
drawing different colors
for the different speed
limit areas where I've gone.
I can even give my users
alerts if they're speeding
to make them safer drivers.
We have a demo showing exactly
that right here at this URL.
You can see the source code,
and you can use it as an example
that you can build it to
your location where app.
We also have full documentation
here on this website.
And I'd encourage you
to incorporate this
into any app that tracks
movement along roads today.
Try out the Roads API
to give your users
beautiful visualizations
of where they've been.
I'm Alex Danilo for the Google
Developer Platform Team,
and don't you "baguette" it.